>>Joe Marini: All right. Let's get started.
Hi, everyone. Good afternoon. Thanks for coming.
My name is Joe Marini. This is Upgrading to
a Chrome Packaged App. I'm a developer advocate
here on the Google Chrome team. You can see
I've used my considerable clout within Google
to get the highly-sought-after end-of-the-day
slot, but thanks, all, for coming.
[ Laughter ]
>>Joe Marini: So before I get started, let
me do the obligatory survey. How many people
have heard of Chrome packaged apps before?
[ Show of hands ]
>>Joe Marini: Wow! That's amazing. Everybody.
Wow. Okay. All right. Thanks very much. Good
night.
All right. Can you guys here me okay? Volume
all right? One of the great things about being
a New Yorker, no one ever says, "Hey, Joe,
can you speak up?"
All right. So here's what we're going to talk
about today. I'm going to talk about why would
you want to build a packaged app, what are
packaged apps all about.
How many people saw Eric Ky's session yesterday
on the state of the nation?
Okay. Not everybody but some of you. All right.
So in that case, I'll go over some interesting
demos as well. So I'll talk about the structure
of a packaged app, why you'd want to do this,
but most importantly, what I want to cover
in this session is the issues that you're
probably going to face when you take an existing
Webapp and go to make a packaged app out of
it.
So let's go ahead and get started.
And by "get started," I mean, let's take a
look at some cool demos.
So if you -- now that you guys have Pixels,
if you set it to be on the dev channel, you
can go to the Chrome Web Store. How many people
have gone to the Chrome Web Store in the past
to get stuff?
[ Show of hands ]
>>Joe Marini: Okay. We lost a few. All right.
There's this thing called the Chrome Web Store,
and in your Pixel, when you go to the AppLauncher,
there's an icon there. It says "Chrome Web
St" and that means store. They just couldn't
fit it all on one line. But you go to that
little shopping bag icon and you'll go to
the Chrome Web Store. And if you do this in
dev channel, you'll see the new UI where we
have some of the newer packaged apps that
our partners have been working on to get into
the store.
So we haven't put these live to everybody
yet. Right now it's only in dev channel on
Windows and Chrome OS, but you can actually
see what they'll look like.
So let me just start off by showing you a
couple of these apps.
This is The Economist, from FT labs, so The
Economist is a great example of an app that
is a content consumption app for -- for both
online and offline.
So obviously the content has to come from
somewhere, so when I'm on line, I can go get
the content, but you notice that here in the
UI, it says "Available to read off line."
So what has happened is, this app, because
it's a packaged app -- and you can tell that.
There's no URL bar -- right? -- there's no
back/forward buttons -- right? -- why would
you want that in an app? It has cached its
data locally.
So, you know, I can go and read stuff off
line, if I make the UI a little bit bigger.
You can also see that it's -- it's responsive
and the nice thing about this is because we
have a rich windowing API, when I close the
app and reopen it, it will remember its windows
position, right?
So these are some of the things -- I'll talk
about this throughout this session, but these
are the kinds of things that you'll need to
remember when you're building a packaged app,
because when you're an app, you now have control
over the window. The browser no longer says,
"Here's how big you are," right? You can control
how big your window is.
All right. Let's take a look at another example.
This is 500 Pixels. How many people have heard
of 500 Pixels?
Right. Oh, good. A good many of you.
So 500 Pixels is a -- is a professional photography
discovery application, right?
So professional photographers use this app
to get their photos out there, and you can
see -- now I'm on my Pixel, right? So I'm
using my finger to scroll through this. You
can see nice touch responsiveness.
Again, works just fine off line. If I kill
the network connection, fire this app back
up, it has cached the data locally and I can
look at whatever photos I had downloaded prior
to losing the connection.
Okay. Let me show one other example.
And to -- oops. To do that, let me just jump
out really quick.
Now, while this is starting up, this is a
game called So Many Me. One of the questions
I get from developers all the time is, you
know, "I've got this existing code that I've
built using, say, Native Client or Unity."
In this case, this game actually was built
-- you can see right here it was built with
Unity. So this is an example of a loud application
that was built using Native Client and Unity,
and it's a game. It's actually a pretty great
game, so I'll just go ahead and start it.
You can see that it's got some nice animations.
Let me go ahead and skip through this part
because I've already done that. But you see
it's, you know, nice smooth game play, right?
You can see the little animated trees in the
background. We've got some blurring effects
going on there.
So again, you can also see here at the top,
when I mouse over the window, that it has
this title bar that comes and goes, right?
So again, another clue that it's -- it's an
app, it's not a browser-based thing.
But to be clear, all the stuff that you're
seeing was built, with the exception of the
game, in HTML5, right?
HTML5, JavaScript, CSS, all of these are built
using native web technologies. They just happen
to be packaged up as applications, and because
they're packaged up using Chrome packaged
apps, they run on four runtimes just right
out of the box. Right? Mac, Windows, Linux,
Chrome OS. And the plan, the vision that we
have for this platform is that these apps
will run wherever Chrome runs.
So in the future, that means Android and iOS,
and we're working with Adobe on the Cordoba
project to make that happen, okay? So that's
six runtimes.
All right. Let's talk a little bit about why
you'd want to do this. So why take a Webapp,
why build a packaged app out of it?
So Webapps are great, right? I come to praise
Webapp, not to bury him, right? We all love
Webapps. They're all really useful. Webapps,
you know, they're great, right? Until they're
not.
There comes a point in time when Webapps are
decidedly not very great, right? We've all
seen -- we've all seen this, right?
So there's a -- there's off line cases. There's
-- there's times when Webapps just simply
don't work very well.
Games, right? Games on the web are awesome,
right? Full keyboard, mouse input. Games just
rock! Until they don't!
Right?
There's times when, you know, you're be building
a game and you want to be able to give your
game players the same kind of experience that
they would get if they were using a real gaming
machine, right?
So access to the USB, access to Bluetooth.
You can't really do that on the open web.
At least not today.
So packaged apps solve a collection of problems
that we've come to notice over the years at
Google and also elsewhere in the industry,
so first, packaged apps run off line by default.
Okay? By virtue of packaging up all your assets
and storing them locally on the machine, you
just get offline access.
Now, that has some implications for app design
that I'll talk about in a little bit.
Packaged apps also give you access to the
platform's capabilities and the platform's
hardware.
So for example, being able to store files
in the filesystem, access the USB and Bluetooth,
right?
In the case of Chrome, because these are built
on our platform, things like synchronizing
data. You know how in Chrome you set your
bookmarks and then you sync them and you go
to some other computer and all your bookmarks
are there, right? As a packaged app developer,
you can also do that. You can take advantage
of the synchronization architecture that we
do.
Packaged apps give you a much richer, immersive
user experience. Right? I mean, you saw examples
of this, right? There are just some applications
where they don't benefit from back buttons
and URL bars. They just get in the way, right?
What does a back button mean in a game like
So Many Me, right? So why not just package
that up as a true app where the user is immersed
in my experience?
And finally, distribution. So distribution
and updates take place via the Chrome Web
Store.
So when you package your app up, you put it
in the Chrome Web Store and now you make an
edit to it and now you want those updates
pushed out to people.
It takes advantage of the same update mechanism
that we use.
So every so often, we ping the server, say,
"Hey, is there a new version of the app?"
If there is, it gets downloaded. You as a
developer don't have to worry about that.
You publish your updates, people get them.
All right. So now that I've talked a little
bit about what packaged apps are and why you
might want to do them, let's start talking
about what it takes to go from a Webapp to
a packaged app. So the structure of a packaged
app is actually pretty simple. In an existing
Webapp, you have all your content, right?
You have your HTML, your JavaScript, your
CSS, and that's what you deliver from your
server. And in the world of Chrome packaged
apps, you continue to use that same structure.
You build your HTML, your JavaScript, all
the assets that you would normally use to
build any other kind of app. All we do is
put some infrastructure around that.
Okay? So we add a -- a manifest file that
explains to the Chrome platform what the app
is, what its name is, what version, what it
can do like permission-wise, so on.
There's a background page and a main JavaScript
file where you specify things like start-up
events, right? You listen for the app being
launched and create your UI. And in fact,
that background HTML page is actually optional.
If all you do is have your logic in the JavaScript
file, we'll just generate that for you.
So really only two things you have to do on
top of your existing app.
So let me just take a quick -- this is a -- this
is, after all, a developer conference. Let's
take a look at some code and --
All right. So let me switch over to my editor.
All right. So here's an example. Can you guys
read the code okay? Yeah? All right. So here's
an example of a typical manifest file, right?
It's just a set of json, and it explains things
like, you know, what the version of your app
is, you know, what its name is, things like
that. So this gets packaged up as part of
the packaging process to go to the Chrome
Web Store and the other part of it is this
file right here.
Now, this -- the code that I'm showing you
is for -- on our -- on our Github, we have
that windowing API example. You'll notice
that it's all just standard JavaScript. The
only thing that we're doing differently is
that we have these Chrome APIs that let you
get richer access to the platform capabilities.
And the philosophy that we've adopted is whenever
the open web provides a capability, then we
just use it.
Right? So file systems and so on.
If it doesn't and there's a need for something,
then we'll fill that in with a Chrome API.
But again, the -- the driving vision is, we'd
like to standardize as much of this as we
possibly can.
So -- all right. Let's go back to the...
Okay. So let's take a look at some of those
issues I brought up earlier, right? So offline
by default.
So again, just to reiterate, everything in
your app, all of the resources, the UI -- right?
-- your graphic assets, everything, that's
all local. Right? That all gets installed
when you install the app. When you install
the app, just like a user would install any
other app, that's -- your experience is I'm
just getting an app.
Now, this has some implications, right? So
first, you have to think about what the disconnected
experience is going to be, including first
run. I might download your app -- right? -- run
to the airport, get on a plane. I've got no
connection. What's my first run experience?
So you need to think about what kinds of features
do you need to make available when you're
off line, right? So not every feature may
make sense off line. And in fact, you know,
if you think about some of the most cloud-connected
applications that are out there, so like imagine,
I don't know, a videoconferencing app like
Hangouts or something, right? Now, obviously
that doesn't work if you have no connection,
so you need to be able to be on line for that.
But there's no reason why, when I'm off line,
I couldn't do things like look at my contact
lists -- right? -- and see a call history
and so on, right?
So even in the case of the most connected
apps, there's -- there's usually scenarios
where things, you know, can and should work
off line.
You need to consider the case of handling
stale data -- right? -- and synchronization.
So the user is working in your app, they're
off line, then they go on line. Now what happens,
right? That's a -- that's an issue.
And again, restore data locally. Now, there
are certain parts of the web platform that
we don't support for very good reason. So
for example, we don't support window.local
storage. Anyone want to know why? Or take
a guess?
>> (Speaker is off microphone.)
>>Joe Marini: It's synchronous, yes. Right.
So synchronous APIs block the UX thread. So
in cases where APIs are synchronous or are
going to cause problems like that, we provide
asynchronous counterparts for them instead.
So in this particular case, you would use
one of the Chrome APIs instead of local storage.
So this means you have to plan for a great
offline experience, right? Factor the app,
figure out what you need to keep off line,
do the things that you would normally do,
keep your JS separate from your HTML, right?
Figure out what you want to make available
off line. You can use web standard events
like the online property and online/offline
events to figure out when you are available,
when you're connected to the web. Store data
with things like Chrome storage local -- in
this case, it's an asynchronous API -- you
can use the HTML5 filesystem to do that. And
in your manifest file, set the offline enabled
flag. That way in the Chrome Web Store, users
can see, "Oh, this works off line," a little
treatment that we give it in the store.
So here's an example of how you would store
data using the Chrome storage API, right?
So let's suppose I've got some value in a
form and I want to save that. Instead of using
local storage, I would say Chrome storage
local and then set, and then that takes a
whole set of key value pairs and I have a
function that gets called when the data has
been stored. Right?
So we've solved the synchronous problem in
that case.
Okay. In addition to offline by default, there's
its counterpart, which is what we call cloud
by default. So today, users increasingly expect
that their data is going to just be everywhere
that they are, and when you build packaged
apps -- right? -- users are going -- they're
going to have the expectation of your app.
They're going to think to themselves, "Well,
you know, I want my data to be where I am."
And again, we provide ways to do that, but
this has implications, right? So they're going
to expect things to sync. Your app is going
to have to figure out how to handle things
like conflicts. And you need to remember that
your app might be used across multiple OSes
and form factors.
So we have a bunch of cloud features in the
platform that you can use to take care of
some of these things, so a few minutes ago
I talked about Chrome storage local. There's
also Chrome storage sync. Chrome storage sync
is pretty much the online synchronization
part of storing data. So this is how, you
know, in our case we synchronize bookmarks.
If you want to synchronize things like preference
settings or usernames or whatever other small
pieces of data, you would use this API to
do that.
We also provide a synchronized filesystem
API to synchronize larger pieces of data.
So for example, if you have, you know, large
files like, you know, megabytes of data that
you want to sync, this is how you would do
that instead.
Now, today, the way that's architected is
it uses Google Drive, but it's open. So in
the future, you know, we might support other
back-end storage, but out of the box, it's
Google Drive.
We also recently announced the Google cloud
messaging architecture, right? The push messaging?
So your server can send push messages down
to your app, and because the -- the Chrome
packaged app system is local and running on
the machine, your app doesn't have to be awake
in order to receive them, right? The runtime
will get the message and the fact that you've
registered a listener for a push message,
your app will be woken up and told, "Hey,
you know, something has happened and I'm sorry
it's 3:00 a.m. but somebody did something."
We also have an identity API. One of the biggest
problems or most confusing things that people
have run into is identity management and authentication.
And so we've built an identity layer into
the Chrome packaged app system to help handle
this.
So we have an API specifically for Google
services, so when a user is signed into Google
-- and on Chromebooks, they always are -- they
never see a login dialogue, right? All they
-- if you call the -- the Google version of
that API, you'll just get the user's identity
and you're off and running. And we have another
one for third-party services. And in the case
of third parties -- right? -- there's a whole
dance that goes on, right? They get redirected
to the app, they sign in, you know, there's
a redirect URL that goes back.
So obviously it doesn't work in apps. So we
built an API that does the same kind of thing,
right? You take the redirect URL, you get
the token, and you're good to go.
So for example, the synchronized filesystem
-- right? -- you can control what the conflict
resolution policy is. You can say, "Hey, the
last write is the one that wins" or it can
be manual, right? You can simply manage conflicts
yourself. And all you do is request the filesystem,
which is the same kind of API that you would
use in the open web, right? You'd get a -- you'd
get a filesystem, a HTML5 filesystem back,
and off you go. You just simply write your
files.
So for the identity case, what I was talking
before about the two different APIs, that's
them right there. So get auth token is the
Google version, and the other one there, launch
web auth flow, is the one for third parties.
Again, so we just -- now, today, those APIs
as of right now are in experimental, so they're
available in the Canary build and such in
the dev channel. You can't currently ship
an application in the Chrome Web Store that
uses experimental APIs but we expect these
to be hitting the stable channel relatively
soon.
All right. Let's talk a little bit about user
experience.
So because these apps live outside the browser
and they can have richer experiences -- right?
-- richer user interfaces, there are some
things that go along with that.
So first, your app is responsible for things
that it wasn't responsible for before when
it was back in the browser. Users have different
expectations of how an app is going to behave
versus a Web site, right? They just interact
with them differently. So the expectations
are slightly different.
So how do you do this? You build a great user
interface. Number one, we give you a rich
windowing API to manage your app's windows.
You can create windows. You can size them.
There are all kinds of events available to
figure out when they've been changed, when
they've been moved, when they've been resized
and so on.
You can do things like use the screen size
to figure out what the initial size of your
window should be. So when the app launches,
you can say, "Hey, how big is my screen,"
do some calculations, center your window,
make it as big as you want.
You should remember where the window is, right?
When the user closes the app and then they
come back to it again later, they are not
going to be happy with the fact that you have
recalculated everything. The reason why they
set the window the way they wanted is because
that's how they want their window, right?
We've all done this. We get sublime text just
the way we want it, right? And then we expect
it to be there.
So in a browser, obviously, you can't do that.
And users don't expect that. They expect the
browser to remember how big it was. Your app
is now responsible for things like that. You
can do things like decide whether you want
the operating system title bar. In the apps
I showed earlier in the demos, they didn't
have the native -- the native title bars,
right? They decided to show -- to hide them.
So you can choose whether you want the title
bar or not. If you don't want it, you still
have to let the user drag your app around.
That's just a basic capability. So we support
the Webkit app region CSS property. All you
do is set that on the element that you want
to act as whatever the title bar is or the
drag region. And we also give you methods
inside the windowing API to do things like
handle maximize, handle minimize, right, figure
out when you open and close, that kind of
stuff.
So we also give you a way to do context menus.
Again, this is an expectation that people
have of apps, right? I control click or I
right click, whatever it is, I expect the
context menu to come up. You can do that in
your apps. We give you that ability.
So I talked also a little bit about access
to the platform and hardware. And so you are
able to get access to the platform via a bunch
of different ways: Files, USB, Bluetooth.
We have APIs for all of that. Sockets, you
can open raw sockets in your packaged app.
So if you want to write the next great IRC
client, you can now do that.
This, of course, has implications. Any time
you give the user access to things like the
hardware, right, security and privacy become
even more important now, right? Now it is
not just cookies anymore. Now it is like,
oh, I can discover devices around me and I
can get files and I can open up raw just data
sockets and start exchanging data with, you
know, anybody I want.
So it's important to remember that these issues
-- you know, they become paramount when you
have these kinds of capabilities.
I believe the wise prophet Spiderman's uncle
once said, "With great power comes great responsibility."
Right? So remember that. So, be clear to the
user about when you're using platform resources.
Now, in some cases you have no choice, right?
The camera comes on. The little light goes
on, right? I'm on air. So in that case, the
platform takes care of it for you. But you
should be clear. Like, you should say, Hey,
here's how much data storage you have used
out of this many bytes. Hey, I'm currently
communicating over connection with this other
computer.
Hey, I'm using the USB to do this game pad.
Or, hey, Bluetooth is currently enabled. Just
give the user some indication of what's going
on.
And, remember, that in many cases these are
shared resources. So, again, this is an example
of where your app is responsible for something
that in the past it wasn't. You need to remember
to release things when you are finished using
them.
All right. Let's talk a little bit about application
security. So how many people are familiar
with the content security policy or have heard
of it? All right. Not many people, okay?
So the content security policy is implemented
inside of Chrome packaged apps. And I will
show you a URL where you can learn more about
this. Basically, it sets up a whole set of
rules for what apps can and can't do. And
we have a lot of rules that are intended to
make applications a lot more trustworthy.
We want these Chrome packaged apps to be thought
of by users as really powerful but at the
same time safe, like, Web pages are today,
right? People feel safe. They go to their
browsers. They click on links, right? They
feel like they can do that without having
to worry about their machine blowing up, whatever.
We want packaged apps to have that same kind
of trust that users have come to give Web
pages. So the first thing we do is we don't
let you do things like eval, right? So don't
be eval.
We don't let you do things like use new function
calls. All your JavaScript code has to be
in separate JS files, okay? You can't -- you
can't do things like inline event handlers
and script blocks inside your HTML. That just
doesn't work.
You can't embed iframes, right? We have a
Web view tag for that, and I will talk about
that in a little bit. But iframes are verboten.
You need to declare where your content is
coming from if it is not coming from your
local app. A great example of this is using
Google Analytics. How many people use Analytics
in their apps? A bunch of you. Yeah. So that
-- by default, the content security policy
will say, oh, you are trying to make a request
to a domain that's not part of your local
app here and so by default that won't work.
So what you need to do is edit the content
security policy for your application to say
I'm allowed to go and get data from this domain.
And the experience that the user will get
when they install the app from the Chrome
Web store will be, Hey, here's what this app
can do, right? It can access data on this
domain, and it can write files, and it can
do these other things. So that's -- it is
a hint to the user of what's going on.
So, again, just to reiterate the point. So
typically when you write a Web page, you'll
see code that looks like this, right? I have
got my script block, my function. I have an
event, says onload, do that. None of this
is going to work, okay? This is just simply
not going to work.
So what you need to do instead is put the
code in an external file and then do things
like get element by ID and whatever else and
add event handlers on the fly, right? That's
a much better way of doing it.
So to embed Web content, this is, of course,
one of the first questions that comes up:
Well, then how do I do things like put stuff
in a frame?
We have actually built a Web view tag to do
this. So if you want to embed content in your
application, you can use the Web view tag.
And the Web view tag gives you the ability
to do things like point at external URLs.
And it gives you an event like, Hey, I have
finished loading the content. So that's how
we solve that problem.
For accessing remote resources, the only thing
-- the only types of data that you are allowed
to refer to that are not local to the machine
in your apps are video and audio. So images
have to be local, right? You can't say image
tag and then path to some image on the Internet.
If we go back to the example of The Economist,
how are they doing that? Or 500 Pixels, how
are they doing that?
What they do is you use XHR to fetch the resources
from the remote location, store them in the
local filesystem Sandbox that you have. And
that's without permission, by the way. Your
app has a local Sandbox for files that you
can just access till your heart's content,
okay?
So then once you have got that, you can refer
to them, like, blob or data URLs. And, in
fact, this scenario comes up so frequently
that we built a remote access loader library
that will handle this for you. You simply
-- you include the JavaScript code. You use
the API and you're good to go.
So then, of course, the question comes up:
Well, what about templating libraries? Don't
they use eval? Don't they use new function?
And the answer is yes. So what do you do?
Well, you can use libraries that precompile
their templates, right? So handlebars, for
example, you can precompile your templates.
Other libraries do the same thing. So do that.
The one escape hatch that you do have from
pretty much everything I have said for the
last five minutes, other than the doors over
there on the side of the room, the one escape
hatch that you have is that you can say, "I
want to run this particular page of my application
in what's called a Sandbox." So back in your
manifest file, you can say you know what?
I want to be able to use eval. I want to be
able to use new function. I want to be able
to use some weird template library that does
all the things you are not supposed to do.
You can declare that that page lives inside
of a Sandbox, and that page is then part of
your application but it is kept separate.
You know, process-wise, it is kept separate.
And then you can just use post-message to
communicate between that page and the rest
of your app. Right? That's how we solve that
particular issue.
All right. So I have got about ten minutes
left. I'm going to try to leave some time
for questions. But let me sum up. So, remember,
offline, by default, right, figure out what
it is you want to make available. Keep all
your stuff local, right? Identify what it
is you want to make -- you want the user to
be able to do.
Cloud by default, we have a great set of APIs
for working with cloud-connected apps. The
sync filesystem, the sync architecture, the
user experience, right? Your app controls
all of that. Your app controls whether it
wants to look native or look like something
people haven't seen before, how its windows
behave, and so on.
Platform access, you can now have a real API
for USB, for Bluetooth, all that great stuff.
Security, remember content security policy,
it defines how your app behaves.
Keep all your code separate and use Sandbox
pages for things that are not safe.
Let me just jump over back to my Mac for a
second, which has helpfully gone to sleep.
Okay. So let's go back to the code and let
me go back -- actually, let me show you on
our site, developer.chrome.com/apps, this
is where we have all the documentation for
how to build these. So if you have any questions
about how the APIs work, you know, we have
all that documented here. We've also got a
full list of the things that are native to
the Web platform that we don't support for
one reason or another.
So, for example, plug-ins, right, Flash, et
cetera, no, no plug-ins supported, no local
storage, right? We don't do things like annoying
alert and confirm dialogues. So all of that
is gone.
Yeah, some of these decisions we made for
security reasons. Some of these decisions
we made because, well, aesthetic reasons.
The other thing I want to show you guys really
quick -- oh, yeah, I'm running Canary, by
the way. So that's bound to happen more than
once.
So these are the Chrome JavaScript APIs. So
where the open Web has you covered, that's
great. For places where the open Web APIs
have not yet caught up or just don't make
sense yet to have an open Web API, this is
where we come in and we give you the Chrome
platform APIs. So this is where we provide
capabilities like the windowing and supporting
things like the DevTools.
And, remember, because these are Chrome packaged
apps, because they're running on the Chrome
platform, you get all the goodness of Chrome.
How many people use the Chrome DevTools? All
right. Did you guys go to the DevTools unleashed
session that was just -- yeah. All of that
awesome goodness that you get in the Chrome
DevTools work here, too.
So while you're developing your app, you can
bring up the DevTools, debug till your heart's
delight, use all the great stuff that we give
you in the DevTools. All the great stuff that
comes in the Chrome platform you get because
you're in the Chrome packaged app.
So let me just take a quick visit over to
the Chrome Web store.
So this is the Chrome Web store as it will
look for you when you go there in the DevChannel.
Now this is on Chrome OS.
Actually, I should probably switch over to
it. Sorry.
This is how it will look. You can see that
the existing hosted apps have been rebranded
as Web sites, and the real packaged apps are
now in the apps category. It actually has
an apps category now. It never had one before.
And this is where apps will be available to
the user. The experience that the user will
get is that when they go to install an app,
right, if they don't have Chrome installed,
we'll take care of putting the runtime on
the machine for them. As far as they're concerned,
it is a runtime. The app will show up in the
launcher like it does for any other app. And
that's the experience that they will get.
Has anyone used inline installation for extensions
before? No? Okay. A few people, yeah.
So one of the features we provide in the Chrome
Web store is a feature called inline installation.
So just the same way that I can go to the
store as a user and get an application, you
as a developer can put a link on your Web
site that will trigger the installation process
inside Chrome. And then from that point out,
the user gets the same experience that they
would have gotten had they gone to the Chrome
Web store.
For example, if I choose to install an app,
I will get a little dialogue that says, Hey,
you really want to install this thing? This
is how many stars it has. You can do the same
thing so the user never has to leave your
site. It works today for extensions and the
hosted apps, and we are going to support that
for packaged apps as well. It is a really
great distribution mechanism because it provides
a nice continuity of flow, right, for users
coming to your site.
Okay. One last thing I want to show you guys
before I take questions. That is something
that we've been working on. It's -- how many
people have opened up their Pixels and said,
"Now, how would I code on this thing?"
Yes, almost everybody. Now, today we don't
have a full-on local IDE. We're working on
it. The DevTools can do some code editing.
There is some great online editors, Cloud
9, Nitrous, all those guys. We thought we
might try our hand at providing an experience
of what code editing might look like.
Now I want to be clear. I'm not about to announce
any great product or anything. So you can
put your phones away. I'm not going to...
What I am going to show you, though, is we
as the team sat down and said, What kinds
of things would an IDE need to do? And then
let's see if we can do that. And this will
teach us what kinds of capabilities we need
to give the platform.
And so down here I've got an application called
code editor. And it is called that because
the developer who has built it has had a ton
of marketing training.
[ Laughter ]
>>Joe Marini: That's what it does.
>>Joe Marini: So... all right. So this is
it. This is the code editor project. This
is on github. And I will show you the repo
in a second.
The idea here basically is that -- you can
see it has kind of got the Googlish UI. So
when I create a project, right, I can create
a new project and I can call it, I don't know,
Joe's demo. And so I will create that.
And so when I do that, it fills out the skeleton
for me of the packaged app, right? So you
can see here -- I mean, I know the font is
kind of small. I'm sorry.
This is the manifest file that you're looking
at right here. Here is the main startup JavaScript
file. You can see here it is creating a window,
right? You can see here it is following the
practice I said before, you know, figure out
the screen height and so on.
I've got things like -- what do you call it
-- code hinting. If I say Chrome dot and then
control space, right? And so pretty cool.
I have got this nice little tabbed interface.
I can switch between my files.
I can also just run this app. I should probably
get rid of the error first, right?
Here's the HTML file. Here's a graphic that
I am including in my app. You can see when
I look at the graphic in the tool, it just
shows you the image. So if I run this, it
will package it up on the fly, build it and
then run it so I can do this edit, refresh,
run cycle. You can see it says "hello world."
I will close that. I will go back into the
HTML and I will change that to say, you know,
"Hello I/O." Don't need to save. We will just
run it again.
Okay. That works. And so at some point, I'm
going to be done with my app and then I'm
going to want to put it in the Chrome Web
store. What do I do? I click export and it
will export this whole project as a zip file
which then just goes right to the Chrome Web
store. This is something we are playing around
with.
The Google Chrome github repo is right here.
So if you want to help us out with any of
this stuff, submit ideas, give us feedback,
please do so. You can see here that we have
the Chrome app samples. So all of the APIs
that I showed you before have corresponding
samples in the Chrome app samples repo here
on github.
And that one -- the aptly named code editor
app is right here. Let's go back. Okay. So,
anyway... looks like I got two minutes left.
So if you have any questions, feel free to
come to the mic and ask them. Otherwise, I
will be up at the Chrome for questions bar
hanging out there. I will be here all day
tomorrow as well. So if you have questions,
please feel free to come ask. And that's it.
Thank you, guys.
[ Applause ]
>>Joe Marini: Oh, we have a line. Great.
>>> Can I use Angular JS to build?
>>Joe Marini: You can use Angular, yes.
>>> Cool.
[ Laughter ]
>>Joe Marini: Oh, yeah, how embarrassing would
that have been? Oh, there is this called CSP
and the Angular guys...
>>> Early on you joked that this wasn't the
death of Web apps but when you showed the
new Chrome Web store, it looks like it kind
of is because in order to be under the apps
category, you have to be an installed app
and the rest of us will be relegated to be
called a Web site.
>>Joe Marini: Yeah, we had to choose branding.
So we couldn't call -- see, the problem is
things like the word "hosted app" doesn't
mean anything to anybody. So we had to figure
out what do we call these -- these new things
are apps. What do we call the old stuff? Before
you rush the stage and just pummel me, just
understand I did not make that decision.
[ Laughter ]
>>Joe Marini: But, yeah, so -- the future
is that, yes, what was called hosted apps
before will now live in the Web sites section.
But they're still promoted. They're still
there.
>>> Does that reflect a direction that Google
is heading, though? Will all of the Google
Apps end up being packaged apps only?
>>Joe Marini: No, we still support hosted
apps. They're still supported. We needed to
make a clear distinction, and that's the way
we went. Yeah.
>>> Do you have any plans to do anything with,
like, the top task bar where you can, like,
put an icon up there? Because sometimes it
is more convenient instead of running it down,
like on the OS?
>>Joe Marini: So, yeah, and similarly like
a system tray icon and things like that.
>>> Yeah.
>>Joe Marini: So, yes, we have looked at these.
Right now we are driving toward a stable 1.0
release. So we want to get the platform right.
Once we have done that, we will start looking
at things like polish and other things we
can do with systems.
>>> Cool.
>>Joe Marini: Yeah.
>>> Thanks.
>>> Can a Chrome packaged app use any of the
Chrome extension APIs?
>>Joe Marini: No. They can't use Chrome extension
APIs. What we have tried to do is in the case
where an extension API made sense in the apps
namespace, we decided to just make it available.
We made an apps version of it.
But, again, for security reasons and other
reasons, we can't use extension APIs.
>>> Okay, thank you.
>>Joe Marini: All right. Other questions?
>>> For an app that's internal to our company,
is there a way to do deployment through an
internal Web store?
>>Joe Marini: Yeah, there is. So we have the
notion of an internal Web store. So, for example,
if you have a Google App account, you can
do automatic provisioning, yeah. So you can
do stuff like that, yeah.
>>> You mentioned API supported Socket. What's
the name of the -- I could not find it.
>>Joe Marini: So it might be in the trunk
version of the docs. It's right here. It is
the Socket docs right here, chrome.socket.
>>> Chrome.socket?
>>Joe Marini: Right here. No, right there.
Hang on. Sorry. Right there. Yeah.
>>> Okay. It is not on the regular API.
>>Joe Marini: If you go to -- it is down in
the list. It is actually in the stable docs.
If you scroll down the list, it should be
listed there, yeah. Yeah.
Yes?
>>> So if I want to download that IDE and
run it on the Pixel, do I have to download
as a zip file from github?
>>Joe Marini: Yeah, you can. When you download
a zip file onto the Pixel -- first of all,
don't do this. The reason is because right
now it requires the Canary to run.
We expect that that will change -- as the
API that we're using makes it into the DevChannel
that will happen. So once that happens, the
download it as a zip file onto your Pixel.
The way -- the incredibly intuitive way that
you unpack zip fills in your Pixel is you
go into the zip file, you select all the files,
you do a control-c, you go back to the filesystem
and do a control-paste and that will unpack
the zip file.
I saved you about five minutes of Googling.
Trust me.
[ Laughter ]
>>> Okay, thanks.
>>> Is there a way to package the Chrome apps
with the Chrome browser installer for OS which
are not Chrome OS, Chromebook?
>>Joe Marini: I'm sorry. Is there a way to
packaged app?
>>> Let's say I created a Chrome app. Now
I want to distribute it not only on Chrome
OS but also --
>>Joe Marini: So it runs --
>>> It runs on the Chrome browser.
>>Joe Marini: No, it runs -- no, you are not
in the browser anymore. No, this is -- what
we have done is taken the Chrome runtime,
factored it out from the browser. So now this
is any other runtime like Java or dot net
or whatever.
You build your app and as far as the user
is concerned, they are just running an app
on a runtime. So they don't know that they're
using Chrome.
>>> I'm getting an executable?
>>Joe Marini: Yeah. So what we do is package
up what is called a CRX file in the Chrome
Web store. That's what gets installed onto
the user system. And then when they launch
it using --
>>> You can only run CRX if you are using
a Chrome browser?
>>Joe Marini: No, you are using the Chrome
runtime.
>>> Outside of the Chrome OS. What about Windows,
Mac?
>>Joe Marini: Windows, Mac, Linux, yes. The
runtime will be installed for the user when
they install the app if it is not already
there.
(Speaker off microphone.)
>>Joe Marini: Yes, right. It is not a browser-based
thing anymore. All right. Looks like I'm over.
Anyway, any other questions, please come find
me upstairs.
[ Applause ]